what a motley looking crew
well congratulations you made it to day
three of the conference or day two if
you're the sort of person who likes to
index from zero I'm thinking a lot of
you like to index from zero so my name
is todd whited we're gonna go on a
strange journey today we've heard lots
and lots of cool talks this week on all
the latest and greatest this is not one
of those talks this is a talk that
seemed like a good idea at the time and
I'm pretty sure it's a good idea but
I'll leave that up to you in the end
what we're gonna do is have a little
good trip back in time to see how they
can address some real world problems
today so just quick poll before we start
get a feel for the room who here has
ever committed code that triggered an
automated build awesome awesome who here
has ever owned a computer that did not
have a hard drive oh nice about half as
many about what I expected
let's try this one who always ever lost
their connection online when their
mother picked up the phone in the
kitchen awesome okay
you're my people you'll get this and for
everyone else thank you for coming to
learn from these experiences so as I
said my name is Todd now like probably a
lot of you I started out as a child
pretty happy child it was in the 70s you
know so everything is kind of that
wonderful purplish tinge that everything
looks like now it wasn't really like
that but I grew up in a family that had
kind of an engineering background my
grandfather had a terrace ad toward
himself to program all this kind of good
stuff so I was around tech from an early
age and I even worked out early on
containers are a pretty useful thing I
still don't know much more about them
than I did back then but that's okay so
I continue to learn about tech and grow
and I had two things going for me
obviously I knew about tech and
obviously I was a pretty snappy dresser
now back then I wasn't really sure where
what kind of career that could lead to I
probably didn't need to worry because
on the other side of the planet there
was some older but not too similarly
dressed people starting a company called
Microsoft notice - micro soft micro -
soft at the time and probably about the
time the photos of me were taken these
guys were making their money licensing
their version of basic to all computer
manufacturers including a company called
Commodore and we'll touch on that again
soon so things progress I got older
luckily as you do grow up through the
80s and when I say the 80s I don't mean
these 80s I know they existed and it's
what people tend to think of as the 80s
this kind of parachutes silk wearing
mullet growing wasn't really my style I
mean these 80s who remembers these
eighties these eighties were awesome
right and your homework after this talk
is to go home and watch all these movies
they're still awesome and it kind of
gave me hope as he as a young kid that
look if I really develop my computer
skills
I might actually meet a girl that'd be
cool failing that you know we can build
one which is only moderately creepy and
look we can be the hero and save you
know maybe save the world true in most
cases we were the ones that put the
world in jeopardy in the first place but
that's that's really not the point so
flash forward years later I've been a
software developer I've been a tech lead
of an scrum master I've been all these
kind of good things worked on projects
really exciting and really scary and
really annoying but found up end up
working at Microsoft talking to people
all about cloud and building awesome
things in cloud and having those
conversations almost inevitably leads to
conversations about DevOps because it is
that not just building the same app
somewhere else it's that kind of idea of
cloud being a transformative kind of
thing with with different ways of
developing and delivering value now this
isn't a talk we're going to go into a
lot about what DevOps is there's been
lots of great talks this week on that
but I do like this definition for a man
from uncle Donovan Brown where he says
it's the union of people process and
products and that order is super
important it's not accidental that order
to deliver value and there's been some
great talks this week on on that and
that's not you know that's the one
Microsoft tends to use but if you look
at Amazon and Google's same concept
right
it's valuing that culture that people
part of it so that's great so I go and
talk to lots and lots of people about
stuff including DevOps and it doesn't
matter whether it's a really big
multinational company or a small
start-up it always tends to start really
well and I'll 12 you know throw out some
facts and figures from the door reports
and things talking about how much more
productive how much more reliable how
much more value that gets delivered but
just inevitably at some point in that
conversation I'll look around the room
because I know it's coming so I just got
to find them I see this guy and I see
the eye roll and I go ha you're my guy
today so this person looks different but
we're gonna use this guy as our model
we'll just pick a name out of the air
hands Gruber he's our guy
right he's clearly not sold on any of
this stuff I'm talking about
and you start to drill in water ease
concerns what are his issues and what's
really interesting is almost always the
objections flip that order around we
talked about it's always the technology
and the products under the problem
that's what's getting in the way he's
not when he's hand up saying I don't
want to change I don't think that
wouldn't be a better thing for me you
know it's all sorts of technical
objections as to why it won't work for
them maybe it's processed but usually
technical so and he throws out a whole
lot of them and the problem with this is
unless you know that technology he's
talking about like in a lot of detail
because he'll just rattle off all sorts
of reasons it's really hard to kind of
say well that's not true and challenging
without going away and researching it so
the idea of this talk was I wanted
something I could just mic drop in a
kind of techie nerdy way to say look we
can do this with DevOps so if we can do
this with DevOps and I admit I don't
know that tech and I'll happy to talk to
you about it but if we can do it with
that I'm pretty sure we can do it with
what you've got
and that's the idea in this talk to give
you that same story to tell and or to
come up with your own one and build this
same thing so I thought what's something
ridiculous I can do because usually when
we talk about DevOps you know we can do
a file new project and build something
new and shiny
it just works it's easy I'm going to
Azure I can go give me a new DevOps
project
it's Java using the spring framework and
it'll give me a hello world app and a
release and delivery pipeline already
built awesome that's not going to
convince this guy all right because he's
not buying into any of this kubernetes
dot core node stuff he's just not having
it so it had to be something more out of
left field
so reaching back into my childhood
although my children will probably tell
you I never really left I thought of
this thing who owned one of these things
nice right the Commodore 64 you're
probably not alone it's still to this
day holds the Guinness Book of World
Records for the most number of computers
sold still today right because they
never changed it it never really
upgraded the one we're going to do use
today users in your case physical case
but the bits are still the same right
and it right it was manufactured for 12
years
alright so imagine what your eye watch
or your iPhone or your Android pod was
like 12 years ago and think if you'd
still be using that so that was pretty
cool
so that's what I decided we use partly
because it's so old and ridiculous and
partly because just like this room lots
of people remember this and remember
what it was like so therefore it would
have a connection that was the theory
anyway
so this thing was powered by the 6502
processor and it wasn't alone
there was a processor developed in the
mid-1970s so powered everything you see
here from the Apple one the Apple to the
Ataris the Atari 2600 and even the
Nintendo Entertainment System and they
even those really annoying little
Tamagotchis all powered by the thing and
it's actually still made today you can
go and buy them so lots and lots of
things had them and if anyone's a future
I'm a fan you might have known as bender
was also powered by a 6502 and if you
were really observant in the first
Terminator movie he was also powered by
a 6502 I have a link to that code if
you'd like it it doesn't create you a
killer robot sadly so the chip wasn't
you
so clearly something else going on for
this thing to be successful well there's
a really frustratingly non-technical
reason Commodore did a fantastic job of
selling this thing so before the
Commodore 64 computers were sold in
computer shops maybe electronic shops
Commodore took them to retailers - you
came out to your Toys R Us and sold them
by the bucket loads it also had another
couple of advantages it had a fantastic
graphics chip something much better than
any girl said and strangely we wouldn't
even think about that
today the sound chip the set was awesome
we're going to get into that but just
just to give you an idea of the scale of
this thing at its peak they were
shipping half a million units a month
right that is more than the rest of the
PC industry including IBM combined this
thing was selling like hotcakes and
there was a reason it was kind of a
virtuous circle because it was so
popular and because it ran for so long
software developers really took to it
right and really starts to learn how to
exploit the platform and there's lots of
business apps and lots of all cool stuff
but you know I don't know probably for
most people in this room we remember the
games right the games were just awesome
actually someone really terrible most
awesome
we could just stop here and watch that
problem but we won't so there's our
challenge that's what I want to get out
of today the hands DevOps challenge so
what do we want to do well first thing
we need to do before we even get to that
DevOps 'part we need to figure out what
is a realistic in a dev loop can we be
productive developers and this stuff
because it's no good having super slick
deployments and monitoring whatever if
the person who's actually building stuff
isn't having a good day so that's the
first chip then as Donovan would say
we're going to rub a little DevOps on it
right so we're going to see how we can
take that program we've built add source
control all those kind of normal things
you would expect in a DevOps pipeline
and hopefully I haven't got any wood
I'll touch this by the end of this we
should be able to do all that and end up
running from a cold start on this thing
we will all think positive thoughts to
the demo gods so when I started thinking
about this I thought okay there's a few
ways we can do this because you know
clearly the scariest ways to do it on
stage in front of people on a real one
that would be ridiculous so obviously
there's lots of good emulators for this
this is a great one and one of the nice
things about the criminal stuff someone
still owns the IP which is always one of
the problems with olds you know shall we
say hazy IP ownership so you can go to
this crowd and you can buy licensed the
Commodore 64 roms in this thing and if
you've got an Amiga you can even go and
buy Amiga ROM chips it's fantastic so
that's an option and we're actually
gonna use that as part of our in a loop
to do our rapid testing if you're super
keen and I was and I bought one of these
you can buy a new Commodore 64 which is
this thing it's called the ultimate 64
and if you see this little thingy up
here all the rest of these connections
up here are the original connections all
good but you'll notice over here it's
got something weird it's actually got
USB ports it's got a HDMI port it's got
a network port because this thing is
actually an FPGA implementation of the
commodore 64 so i thought well that's
fantastic so i bought one of these
because now you know i don't have to
worry it's easy to connect its whatever
and i did a version of this presentation
and a guy came out to me the end and
said that was awesome but you were still
cheating okay all right fine
and oh by the way already told a few
people someone
he bought the molds for the cases so
there's a guy in Germany you can go to
his website and order yourself a brand
new commodore 64c case in any color you
want which I did but we can't use it
because that's cheating apparently so
we're gonna use this this is an original
1985 ish I think commodore 64c
unmodified i just took it off cleaned
off the goop check the capacitors hadn't
exploded and we're all pretty good right
so we're good to go
well not quite strangely enough I open
the user guide something I probably
never done because you know it's this
thick it's not like a modern user guide
and it had this awesome diagram of how
to connect it there's two big problems
on this and the first one is this see
this little simple rectangle here it
looks so simple plug in the power supply
don't plug in the power supply these
things are terrible even when they were
brand new they had a failure rate of 30%
right because these things were made by
the millions and it was just easier to
replace them to fix the problems and
just to make life a little interesting
it has no voltage protection so when it
does fail it fries your computer so
don't you do that so I had to get a new
power supply built I've got this one
here a Rey Carlson won one of the
original Commodores service engineers
he's online you can go on and he'll
build you whatever you like so awesome
we can plug it in we've got power now
the next problem is this now the younger
people here probably don't recognize it
my kids didn't recognize it
yes that's what televisions used to look
like now I don't have a television that
looks like that I don't have a
television with the connections that
look like that so how are we going to
get this to display on this big screen
up here well look it's pretty
straightforward because the Commodore 64
actually had three ways of sending
signals RF which you would tune on your
television station right well that's out
I don't have one of those anymore I've
got one of these things right and I'll
CD so that leaves us composite and a
thing called luminance and chrominance
which you may not recognize but if I
call it s-video might make more sense
and this is basically the forerunner to
s-video
but of course just to make life
interesting it's not compatible with
this video the the signal strength is
out that's okay and just to make it even
harder this is the plug alright so no
plug goes into that so that's okay so
luckily we have the Internet
so someone has
this thing called the super a V adapter
which is up here plugs into the back
ease in the cord and splits it out for
us into an s-video and some RCA audio
which was really handy my good friends
in in the crew up the back because when
I got here I realized it doesn't the
audio from HDMI doesn't actually play
here so we head to quickly luckily it's
got those jacks and that's awesome right
we can plug that into something now well
not quite because that video signals
still running at 15 Hertz which is
really slow it's probably slower than I
could run right no modern display will
display that so we need to add a line
doubler or an upscaler to take that
signal do some funky digital stuff and
get it running fast enough oh now we can
connect super exciting now when we do
this we got that now one of the
interesting things about the 64 you see
up here basic v2 and you remember my
Microsoft friends this is Microsoft
basic license to Commodore one of the
really clever things a guy called Jack
Tramel which is what I'm saying thank
you jack did Whitney negotiated with
Microsoft is he'd negotiated for $50,000
and unlimited loyal royal runtime
unrestricted license he could sell as
many as he wanted for that that's a
mistake Microsoft wouldn't make again a
few years later when they did a deal
with IBM alright but what that meant was
he bought that in the mid seventies he's
not going to pay another buck he's not
that kind of guy so this is basically
the same version of basic that shipped
all the way back in the mid 70s so it's
a great computer I can do lots of good
things didn't have a lot of cool stuff
that came with it so there was missing a
few common things you know we might kind
of take for granted today you know
things like directory listings and
copying a file and you know those sort
of things now didn't really have time
for that so this is how we loaded the
directory back in the day sure
everyone's remembering that you would
load dollar comma right and you would
list and there's your directory of
course if you've been writing any
programs it just got wiped by doing that
directory listing okay stuff happens so
this thing what we see here it's not
really a command line it's actually a
full screen editor right you can do
whatever you want and go all over the
shop the problem is if I wanted to do
some
simple hello world and I'm sure more
than one or two of you went into Kmart
on the display unit and type this in and
ran because you know we struck a blow
for nerd freedom but if we wanted to do
anything more complicated than that you
had to start doing this stuff poking
which is not as exciting as it sounds
and peeking is not as bad as it sounds
basically we're writing stuff directly
in a memory and we personally I get code
and I'd type this stuff in and if I did
these commands you know look and I'm
gonna be it would show up there I've no
idea why at the time right it would go
on and on so there's lots of weirdness
about this machine that's okay so we
need to set up a dev tool dev tool
changer let us work in that weed
environment but be productive so we
could do this on the Commodore 64 but I
don't want to it isn't fun it wasn't fun
back in the day and in fact a lot of the
programs for it were not developed on it
so we're going to take that same model
so the first thing I need is an editor
now I'm going to use vyas code I like
v/s code who uses vyas code or awesome
if you have a look at the stats from
Stack Overflow and things the other
advantage of this is this is not just
popular developers it's popular with IT
pros and all sorts of other things so
thinking back to our hands what we're
trying to show him that this is a tool
maybe that everyone can use not just
developers so that's really cool we've
got that now because I'm not working on
the Commodore 64 I need to have some
kind of cross assembler something that
can take it and generate the code I need
frightening me enough there's a lot of
them I pick this one because if you look
at the date the active dates on these
things they're actually still heavily
developed and heavily use so awesome I
can use this and compare assemble I'm
not going to compile we'll get that a
minute then for my inner devil OOP we're
gonna use one of those emulators I spoke
about because I don't want to have to
deploy it to the 64 to test it I want
something much faster than that for that
in a loop so we use that super cool but
then for the dev ops I'm gonna use again
that stuff I know right I'm going to use
github for the repo and then as your
develops boards and pipelines for all my
other DevOps stuff pretty
straightforward so awesome we've got an
environment now if I do that and I fire
up my code I get this so cool I've got
an editor it's pretty much notepad at
this point right there's
no intellisense there's no color-coding
there's no anything that I'm usually
like but you know it's Visual Studio
code I could write an extension right
well turns out I don't need to if you go
into the extensions as a social
Commodore 64 there's already a whole
bunch yeah yeah in community and this is
actually more amazing than you think
because I don't need an extension that
does Commodore 64 code because each of
those assemblers actually has their own
syntax and whatever so I found one for
the exact cross assembler I'm going to
use so happy days
we've got intellisense we've got color
syntax highlighting all that good stuff
okay
oh now one thing you will notice back in
this day of course there's no kind of
project file the solution file you know
all the source code is explicitly in you
know built into here so therefore you
know Visual Studio code doesn't know how
to build this thing so I could do it
from the command line but again Visual
Studio code for the win it has the
concept of tasks you can just create
this little you can create this little
task JSON file you can tell it what the
command line you want to run in this
case I'm calling the Acme compiler
giving it some parameters and hey presto
I can just go run tasks and do what I
want to do now one thing I did learn
along the way I started off just by an
assembling and deploying it to the thing
that sounds awesome
the thing I found even with a simple
program it ended up being about 100k you
get 100k that's awesome it is until
you're trying to hold it on the
Commodore 64 100k takes a long long time
so I actually found you needing another
tool which would compress that file down
to about 2k and when we get to the end
of the demo when you see how long it
takes to download 2k you'll appreciate
why that was important so we've got a
dev environment
we're productive we can build stuff
let's think about the code we've got a
build for a hello world app so if we
were doing this in dotnet core we could
go dotnet new console and I'm pretty
much walking off the stage I'm done all
right here's our hello world it's
created namespaces it's done all these
kind of things if I got really really
excited I could add a few lines
and add some color to it right and if I
run that awesome I've got a hollow will
down but to make that magic happen
there's a lot of stuff helping me all
right so there's dotnet core runtimes
their system libraries there's OS level
stuff there's video card drivers the
exciting news is we don't have any of
that on the Commodore 64 right and it's
probably a little bit of a clue when you
open the user guide not the programmers
guide the user guide it gets all the way
to chapter two before it starts teaching
you how to code that was a first clue
that huh okay this might be a little
more work and of course if you actually
look at the programmers guide which goes
into a little bit more detail it tells
you how to do pretty advanced stuff and
if you open up the back it has a full
schematic on the motherboard I don't
know how many of your programmers
reference guide have a full schematic of
the motherboard there's a reason for
that we're going to need to know this
stuff so strap on this is where we get a
bit low level so I kind of told a lie
before I said the Commodore was powered
by the 6502 it's actually powered by the
6510 which is the same the commodore
actually bought the company MOS that
made the 6502 so now they can do
whatever the hell they want so it's the
same chip they just reorganize the pins
a bit to make their life easier so what
we have on this thing's is eight pins
for the data bus so that gives us 8-bit
bytes 0 to 255 is our biggest number and
then it's got this wonderful 16-bit
address bus so we can address up to 64 K
hence a Commodore 64 which was so
important in the time it's in the title
not much of a shock the funny thing is
when you power up the 64 here tells us
64 K Ram awesome and I've got 38 K free
what the heck you're not doing very much
why have I only got that much memory
well turns out if you open up the
Commodore 64 you see all these cool
chips so over here is the Vic this thing
does the display here's our wonderful
seed for our sound so here's the kernel
yes it's built that way
the basic that all Microsoft stuff and
the character sets here this handles all
the input/output but the only way any of
these things can talk to each other is
via that same address bus so if we look
at our 60
okay and memory lots and lots of memory
we can address 64k but this yellow bit
that's the only bit we can use because
things like the cartridge ROM because
these things take cartridges so that's
blocked off we can't use that this thing
has all these other things and some
special bits of memory up here oh yes
there's our xxx okay if we have a look
up here in this green there's a thing
called screen ram because when we want
to write our program we're gonna have to
actually write directly to memory so
we're gonna deal with that
and there's another block way down the
bottom for some reason to deal with
color because in effect we have this
screen memory map for the commodore
screen which is 40 columns across 25
down awesome which is all little memory
locations now these things we can't draw
pixels on the commodore 64 all right
these are cells these hold a character
all right so if we won an A in the top
corner we could type poke 1,024 comma 1
1 being an A we get an A if we do want
to put something down to Reliance across
a little bit we've got to figure out how
many cells across that is perfect we can
get a B so that's the kind of thing
we're gonna need to do unfortunately
it's still not that simple because we
can't write to an address memory
directly that would be way too easy so
here's what we're gonna have to do we're
gonna have to work out what the value of
our character string is specifically put
into a bit of memory you know none of
this variable stuff actually write it to
somewhere in memory and then who's build
BOTS it's excited by but are they not
the same BOTS
do these guys get into your gig I don't
know but we've got a new bit of memory
here with our message in it all we're
gonna do is load it into these special
registers put it into there so put it up
into the accumulator hmm cool and then
give it another command to copy it off
to the screen do so that's what we're
gonna have to do now luckily the the
assembler does gives us some helpful
little utility so I don't have to do
that byte for byte I can just give it a
string and it'll do that magic so that's
really cool and then just all I gotta
really is is some really simple looping
copy you know set an index load into the
accumulator that store it line by line
character by character copy
across to get some text on the screen
this this by the way is when it can
really in the Windows 10 calculator is
awesome
cuz you can add you know binary 1 1 0 1
2 hex whatever and it'll give you the
answer really really handy and I won't
say stop me going insane but certainly
slowed it down after we do all that
we've got some text on the screen huh ok
that was a little bit more work
remembering that aim of this exercise is
to convince hands
he hasn't got anything that isn't harder
than this right but there's still
something missing right that's that's
cool
it's a hello world it's certainly not
very 80s though so we're not really you
know kind of showing off what you would
really do on the platform so we need to
add some color all right so I don't if
anyone remembers the weird palette of
CGA and all those kinds of things and
the Apple 2 or some 4 colors at a time
the Commodore 64 could do 16 it was
awesome
guess what same same idea we've got
another big slopper memory there's
different colors and basically for each
cell we tell it what the foreground
color background color away we go so
that's really cool there's no helpful
for this so for every little bite in
that array we've got to do it bye bye
bye to specify the different colors and
then we're gonna have a cool little loop
which again same sort of thing right set
some Index store in the accumulator and
store it into the screen memory and once
we do that we can go a little exciting
run the task to do that'll fire up our
little emulator run it now we've got
some color now we're looking a little
more 80s it's getting it it's getting
there but what's missing come on who
lived in the 80s computer games sound
thank you
sound is missing we haven't met the seed
yet so the city's awesome and in fact I
don't think even Commodore realized how
cool this was at the time you could only
play three voices three sounds at a time
in the vic-20 it's pretty decisive could
play for alright and it could play only
these one two three four different
waveforms but what it could do is two
things one you could really control the
whole lot of variables about that sound
but also you could change it on the fly
people eventually worked out
different channels can make different
sounds so to give you an idea what that
means let's kind of visualize each of
these lines is one of those three points
[Music]
and you gotta remember think back this
is Apple two days this is where most
computers are going be weird dude bleep
dude this is pretty cool and there was
actually a bug in the chip that affected
the volume and what some really clever
programmers work out who remembers this
game right what was cool about this game
the speech right so this they added a
way to work out did you add digital
samples by exploiting a bug in the
volume control because the volume is
just binary on or off so if you flick
that really quickly you can create some
really cool sounds now it's all coming
back and people are starting to remember
this a little more fondly I missed this
I was really annoyed if you're in
England a few months ago you would have
seen this this is a full orchestra
version of some of the best commodore 64
game music that was ever done
[Music]
awesome awesome stuff so given how hard
it was to add text to our screen how
hard do we think it is to add sound to
our program who thinks it's going to be
easier than the text
who thinks is gonna be harder alright
let's have a look that's it
what the heck okay the first thing we're
doing up here
we're just remember I said we've got to
tell it exactly where in memory wanted
to put our stuff this is just defining a
few variables with a memory location
that's all it does we have one line that
says bin so read a binary file of the
CID file this is the music file and then
we this is forget this this is just the
label we jsr to that memory location jsr
meaning jump to subroutine what the heck
turns out when you write music the music
file doesn't just contain the music it
contains all the machine language
instructions to run that music
separation of concerns not such a big
thing in the 80s but made my life easier
so what the heck so we can add that
we've got a CID file we can do our
little terminal run task again and fully
all being well we're starting to get a
little bit closer to where we want to be
that that's definitely feeling a little
more aged
so we kind of got out in a devil oops
sorted now we're going to put some damn
pops on it but to do that I've actually
created and that was version one that
was good I've now got version two and
we're going to push version two through
our DevOps pipeline okay so really I
mean Visual Studio code I'm using github
so really forget that it's a Commodore
64 I'm just committing code there's
nothing special here we're now kind of
at the point where a lot of these the
peculiarities of the Commodore 64 won't
matter right we're just using all their
normal git tools
putting in a vaguely useful message
committing it and pushing that up to
github okay so what we're going to have
to do here here's kind of the steps we
did on our local PC we add Visual Studio
code we assembled it we compressed it
and we launched it we're gonna commit
that code up to github and obviously an
azure pipeline we need to somehow
replicate those same steps or see if
there's another way to build it now I'm
not going to drill into this but you
know I'm a developer obviously so I
spent lots of time putting really
detailed user stories and ignored most
of them but yeah in the real world you
would do that do you hit a slight snag
when I went to configure my pipeline I
looked at all the build agents as you
gives you which is awesome Windows Linux
Mac there isn't a Commodore 64 one I
personally feel this is a failure I've
raised a user voice if you'd like to go
and support that do that but that's okay
we can just use the same thing we'll use
across assembler now this is where it
gets good because Asia DevOps has a
really good marketplace and a really
good way to build extensions so all I'm
going to do now is build an extension
that installs and runs those exact same
tools I ran on the PC now I'd never done
this before but it's not that hard it
took me about half a day their
typescript which again I hadn't done
before done lots of JavaScript but not
typescript but same diff so really
that's what I'm gonna do so to do that
it's basically there's a tutorial you'll
follow inside an extension you can
install multiple tasks so in here I've
put specific ones around installing the
tasks and then for running each of the
tasks the especially just a manifest
file which is all the info that pops up
in the marketplace when you can discover
it so here's mine
it's I don't want to you know too
horn but it's definitely in the top two
acne cross compilers available on the
edge of DevOps marketplace well that was
just unnecessary yes there are only two
and the other one didn't work that's why
I had to even do this anyway so the most
of the code in that extension is really
just metadata it's stuff you're gonna
use to make it discoverable so you can
see here we got you know version
information we've got a whole lot of
inputs to find and really that's just so
that when you install stuff pops up over
here you know okay here's the this
particular task and there and the other
important thing though is you define
what are the inputs you need to give
this build step so there's a few
different types here you can see he
would got picklist
which gives you like a nice drop-down
list because the acne compiler can
actually compile for a whole lot of
different architectures all that kind of
good stuff and what that means is when I
install my task rather than I think it
remember magic strings I get pick lists
I get dropdowns I get all that kind of
good stuff
so that just makes my life easier then
within my module when I want to get that
value cancel' than sdk you basically
just say get input that's it not
particularly complicated right so and
then there's a whole lot of other
utilities to do things like download at
all oh yeah I don't have to do that
myself just download it extract it and
then it has a caching mechanism so I can
if I call it again it doesn't actually
go and get it it's all good stall it to
the marketplace boom you can go and
enjoy it today pretty straightforward so
my build pipeline looks like this you
know install the Acme tool install the
cruncher assemble it using a whole lot
of variables I set over here all the
usual stuff there is a couple of extra
steps I didn't do before generate file
ideas remember that we'll come back to
that in a minute
basically just generate a little
metadata file with some of the building
folk will come back to them and I'm also
decided I'm actually going to distribute
this in a couple of different ways not
just the program but also as a disk
image so people can download it as a
disk cool and of course I had the Chuck
Norris build step because Chuck Norris
is awesome so when we do that we run
through we get this nice summary all the
things that worked and a little bit of
chuck norris wisdom he doesn't call dr.
suppose he calls dropkick we set in the
mood
carrying on right we can drill in if we
want drill into all the build details
okay so we've got full access to that
and after all that we've actually
produced three artifacts our hello world
- which is what we're gonna run a hello
to D 64 which is a 1541 disc image also
containing the program file and that
little metadata file we spoke about and
of course I get dashboards and all the
kind of good stuff I don't have to do
too much there it just all shows up
awesome so we've got our CI kind of part
working now it kind of gets fun now we
need to do the delivery part alright so
we had a few different ways of doing
this back in the 80s you could just
merge them scene involve printing out
the code and making everyone type it in
again so these books were awesome I
don't if anyone else remembers these
books they're all for free and available
on the Osborn site go and look at them
they are fantastic you did just have to
cope with the fact that the amazing
artwork didn't always live up to the
game once you finally got it running but
that's okay or you could get it from
magazines where again you would type it
all in hope you didn't make a mistake
hope they didn't make a printing mistake
and maybe it'll run and if the magazine
was really cruel they just give you this
machine language thank you tuck that in
alright but you know that sounds
particularly fun and I don't think you
guys want to do that so the other way
obviously was physical media we could do
this with cartridges in Australia in the
UK all the most games are on tape
because this these floppy drives were so
darn expensive but later on certainly
floppy disks so that's what we're gonna
use today sort of we're gonna use that
virtual floppy disk for one part and
then we're going to download the probe
the program physically in the other way
so how do we do that well I've set up
because believe it or not there is a
JavaScript emulator for the commodore 64
it's actually pretty good
so i've set up a static website using
the hugo static site generating
framework because i'm trying to keep the
cost down here so it's just static site
i my pipeline is really just going to
deploy that d 64 file to blob storage
and then I have an azure function which
just every time something's happens on
that it regenerates a JSON file
containing a list of what all the disk
images that are available right and then
I used some CDM so now I can get HTTP
and custom domains and more
so I'm going to share this website with
you later you can go and go crazy on
this it's very very cool okay so here's
our website what you can see we've got I
started publishing all the info related
to this up in the articles but there's
an online 64 and a terminal will talk
about the terminal set but if you go to
that page this is a fully functional on
c64 you can go crazy type your thing in
okay I did keep forgetting to turn the
sound on so I'll turn on the sound then
I can browse here pick some of the disk
images load that disk image up this is
version 2 there's another version one we
saw before I've added a little bit more
Jewish because you know it's the 80s
there we go
same ideas just with a little more
graphic but you'll hear the particularly
the sound it's struggling to keep up
right pushing the engine cool so now
we've got that's that's basically going
to serve as a new ad environment people
can go in there quickly test it find an
easy bugs and then we're going to
deployed a prod so how do we deploy
things electronically back in the 80s
who remembers bulletin boards awesome
this is the part where your mother
picked up the phone and screamed
okay so these were really simple these
are awesome you could connect a modem up
your Commodore 64 dial a phone number
connect it all up the problem is if you
wanted to send messages or files or
anything to someone somewhere else you
either had to dial this TD like really
expensive you know just think darling
America type charges in the day all
right that wasn't a thing so the good
thing was the bulletin board people got
together and built networks and what
they would do is you'd post your file or
your message to your local board and
then these boards periodically would
dial each other up and just pass it
along right there was no I'm not sending
a message to this guy I'm sending to all
the boards on the network and this board
eventually got hey that's for me so
security not much of a thing but that's
okay so that's what we're gonna do so
I've set up on an asia vm the mystic
bulletin board system that was a little
of a learning experience
again the good thing is there's still a
community that maintains this so they've
added support for internet protocols
like telnet and FTP and things or
awesome there is still one problem they
still assume you can even though it's
old that you can at least display an 80
characters all right come on a 64 member
40 so that's still a problem we've got a
deal
oh we're gonna have to hustle so I've
set up a bulletin board BBS dot retro
DevOps comm and believe it or not these
networks still exist so there's a great
one run by a guy in New Zealand and but
now at least because we can use the
Internet we don't need to do it one by
one we can just dial into a central hub
and pass that along so here's what it
looks like beautiful ASCII art running
there and of course because it's running
on the toll net port it gets smashed
every six seconds by um by a North
Korean friends but that's okay it's got
it's got ways did you take that cool so
now we're getting close to the physical
thing so to get that to work we've got a
few more things this is the smaller
revamped Commodore 64 disc drive which
is actually about yea big and I only buy
100 grams made my luggage allowance with
this thing so that wasn't an option to
bring that down unfortunately but that's
alright I've got these little brother so
this little doohickey here takes an SD
card and implements and emulates a
Commodore 1541 Drive awesome we can
store and run stuff and then we need to
connect so luckily again
yeah Internet this little guy plugs into
the back of the Commodore thus far is a
Commodore 64's concerned it's a modem I
talk modem commands to it if anyone
remembers the Hayes compatible 80
commands back in the day same thing but
the top half is Wi-Fi there we go so my
release pipeline again now looks pretty
simple right
I'm a good developer I'm not going to
put my credentials in the pipeline other
codes so I put them in as your keyboard
and pull those in as I need them I copy
the program files from the build into
the directory now the board build system
wants it as a zip file so I'm going to
zip those files up and that's where that
metadata file we generated before
because the bulletin board will actually
look inside pull that out and use that
to populate its info so cool and we
deploy to the ball board luckily for me
it supports FTP otherwise I would just
have built another custom extension to
talk it's weird protocol we run our
things
everything looks green hands still not
convinced ok this is the part where
things get a little hairy let's see can
we really really do this on a Commodore
all right from a cold start
he said if you feel free to cross
fingers or whatever
Wow it's blue isn't it who remembers
that blue deep deep deep in our psyche
okay now you want might notice the fast
load so I've also got in here a fast
Epic's fast load cartridge there was a
bug in the commodore disc drive from
1982 in the vic-20 that they never
bothered to fix that would cost money
that made things really slow so people
created these cartridges that fix that
problem so what I'm gonna do forgive me
as I look down here first thing I need
to do so here's all the disk images on
there now this is effectively the
equivalent of me coming along and I want
a clean one with nothing and I'm putting
the floppy floppy disc in the drive now
once that's done cool now how do I get a
directory of that again come right this
is a lot faster if I did this without
the fast classroom things like this take
about five minutes so we can see all our
files here awesome and this has our
terminal program we're gonna use to
connect again if I did this without the
fast cast
past that's really hard to say fast load
cartridge that would take about 10
minutes so it's gonna start up it's
gonna still load take few more seconds
going to load some files so this is
basically had a little terminal program
that's going to connect us hopefully to
our bulletin board system and we're
gonna go from there so well no I'm not
because why is that he says not checking
that he's phone he's sharing it's
connection just talk amongst yourselves
it's all fine any questions while I'm
you know is it did anyone notice to the
1984 tech is working just fine yeah did
anyone notice how long it took to boot
the Commodore 64 yeah that's right load
times come on yeah tethering yes
tethering has turned itself off someone
there's a bit of battery saving stuff
we're going I don't think he really
needs that yeah I do I really do
okay so let's try that again
this little modem ething has a very cool
little um LCD screen so I can see okay
now it's connected okay let's try that
again
yay for faster the cartridge and the
funny thing was I did not plan to do
this today this was all going to be
running and we just jumped in this damn
and I thought is someone gonna still say
I cheated cuz you know I have that fear
so we're doing it from cold for good or
bad but you know we're all friends here
okay quit
that's the shorter way of doing a set of
loadstar comma common or run stop yay
okay it says ready I don't know if
that's like a status or just it motional
II feel ready but we'll we'll kind of
figure that out I'm just watching my
time okay cool terminal emulation so we
can see here we've got a modem connected
to the user port 2400 baud that should
be enough for anyone usually when I tell
it to my phone I complain about the
speed now it's like that so doesn't
matter whole lots of other good stuff
aunty yep all good so if I jump over
we're gonna jump into let me turn that
status line off that'll confuse me okay
so if I jump over here is where I can
take my my good old ati commands we can
see how cute the outgoing port is 1541
and under the disk drive and incoming
port is 64,000 okay so cool I go to my
phone directory it's a little slimmer
than it used to be but that's okay and
we're gonna die on the stead of a phone
number retro devops BBS comm port 23 and
I can run that at any port and probably
should have to prevent people port
scanning my hotel now but on the website
which you saw earlier there's also a BBS
client which will proxy through and
that's why I've lifted that way so you
can go to the website jump on there and
actually connect to the bulletin board
and create an account for your cell
phone where you go and you got to love
security back in the day if you type in
an account name that doesn't exist it
says oh there's no such account do you
want to join and be one it's like yeah
okay
okay now I'm the size up so it's gonna
ask me a few interesting little
questions
it was character do you want add a
one-liner to give people a screw home
how I'm gonna get some electronic mail
and I'm betting yet possible hacker team
so that's all those North Korean friends
good morning to you all
okay so here's our beautiful menu
loading up at 2400 board now again
mention where I said most of these
bulletin boards assume you've got 80
columns so I've kind of created a custom
style to a not put as much on the screen
because it takes way too long to draw
but you will still see some little
wrapping things I haven't quite figured
out so we're gonna go to the files area
you gotta wait sometimes if we have a
look at the files area the one we're
gonna look at these uploads but you'll
see those ones that say fsx so they're
the areas where it's passing bottom
files around all the different boards
but we're gonna go to one kept that
simple because scrolling through a long
list is not fun
we can go let's have a list of the files
and we're gonna see hopefully two things
here whatever the latest version is
because I only keep latest ones so one
is we've gap we've just put the program
file but then we've also created that
disk image so you can see here hello dot
zip and then that little description
underneath it wrapped unfortunately
contains all the things so how do we
download this file you'll notice on the
menu there's no download command hmm you
tagged it because remember downloading
takes a while so the model back in the
days you'd browse around tagging the
files go and tell it to start the
download and then you know you'd go and
watch a couple of movies and you'd come
back alright so we've tagged that file
now if we come back a menu and we say
downloads well yeah why would have typed
downloaded anyone there's our file 2k
remember the compressed version now
we've got a pic a protocol yeah we have
to know a little bit more back in the
day okay Zed modem sounds good
no okay this is where you go to hustle
because we've got to tell it to start
sending it and then tell the commodore
64 to start receiving it we've got to do
that fairly quickly are we ready what
could possibly go wrong
send that download
it's a program oh don't you love it we
can actually watch the bytes come down
magic so remember this is 2k do you
understand now why I didn't want the
hundred K uncompressed version come on
you're nearly there
you're nearly there the bytes look so
nice oh thank god demo gods be praised
all right
now how do we get out of here well not
that simple we go back to the main menu
and we're going to do with the quick way
which is we say goodbye isn't that nice
okay let's get out of here now
if the gods are kind we will have yes
it's so hard because the key it looks
like a QWERTY keyboard but little things
like you know star quotes equals have
their own key somewhere else not up on
the top row so it does kind of mess with
your head a little bit that should be
fine Oh
fingers crossed toes crossed please work
Hey
and how much better does sound on the
for JavaScript version we could just
listen to that for a long long time
because they've got a minute okay so I
do not expect you to go home and have
this insane desire to write 6502
assembly language but let's take a vote
who agrees that at least satisfies the
criteria it is not a cloud friendly
platform we've added DevOps we all agree
awesome that was the whole point
no I've gotta stuff I'm really sorry I'm
sorry it's not you it's me okay let's
switch back over so so darn simple
hey we're back okay it's cool so what do
we do let's reflect so I would argue and
I hope you'd agree we've certainly got a
productive in a dev loop okay we've got
everything that you could feel
productive is it about I can't help you
it's a language I'm sorry that is what
it is but you know we've got an editor
that our devs would know probably our IT
pros can use if you have a look at the
Stack Overflow stats in their surveys
it'll tell you the IT pros use Visual
Studio code now more than anything else
so that's good
we did all there 8-bit stuff but then we
did our devops pipeline now completely
honestly that was a very simple pipeline
but the point is now we've got that end
and working all the other magic stuff
that comes with it as your DevOps we can
just turn on alright so we can have
approval flows that log tickets in
service now you know we can do all sorts
of cool and funky things but we've got a
running pipeline we're being pragmatic
along the way we also managed to do a
little bit of mr. miyagi we kind of
snuck in some extra things there you
would have seen right I didn't show it
but all there as your resources there
obviously are templates that get
deployed by another pipeline the
websites another pipeline are the
extensions in github and I'll deploy to
the azure marketplace in a pipeline we
managed to use Aya's paths and
serverless stuff in there right so we
used all the cloud things awesome and we
got - boarding alerting all that kind of
good stuff and again we could have gone
a lot further the really funny thing
though is as I built this out and I kind
of figured out bit by bit it started to
feel really familiar and I thought this
is really strange and then it finally
dawned to me where I've done this so
some of the customers I've worked with
doing lots of IOT stuff and if you have
a look at the Microsoft recommended IOT
edge devops pipeline it's exactly that
you do your stuff on your VPS code you
deploy on a dead branch it deploys to
simulated devices running on containers
or VMs in the cloud to do your testing
merge that back and then push down to
the IOT edge device to push out to your
potentially really old hardware so even
though it's kind of a ridiculous example
the actual framework and model is
completely valid so now we've just got
to ask one question after all that do we
think hands is happy hands are still not
happy yeah
he buys it he gets it that it'll work
but it's also driving that everything's
code now infrastructure everything I'm
gonna say yeah yeah yeah hands baby it's
okay and in fact to calm him even more
let me just go back to the original
Commodore 64 training video don't you
have to be a programmer you don't know
oh sometimes programming can be most of
the fun
why else would somebody stay up until 3
o'clock in the morning cursing and then
claim the next day that they had a
wonderful time
1984 come on we've all been there right
now hands hasn't been there right the
hands of the world they've developed in
a different different domain right their
world is all about stability regularity
repeating it's not about rapid change
and learning so it's a big shift for him
so this is where the homework comes in
so I hope you've enjoyed that I hope it
was fun I hope the people similar age to
me are gonna run off immediately and
start downloading some Commodore 64
stuff but really that's not the key
takeaway the key takeaways how do we
make hands happy because we want happy
hands and this is where you know I put
this down to something as simple as for
developers to really think about what it
means to be a good DevOps citizen so
what can we do to help because we have
lots of skills right we've lived in a
cold world for a long time you know
we're really comfortable with things our
code and how to work with code and how
to collaborate with other people around
code right because you think about a lot
of other types of IT people people in
traditional infrastructure environments
they collaborate but they collaborate
kind of at a planning level and then
everyone goes and does their beat and
then comes back they're not used to that
really necessarily that really short
collaboration so we can sort of share
that experiences also I've put there
being practical if anyone saw Damian's
great talk yesterday I'm being pragmatic
with DevOps that's probably a better way
that I should have put that but being
pragmatic that things aren't gonna be
perfect we're gonna have to learn and
it's safe and we can learn and failure
is not necessarily a bad thing unless it
keeps happening right but conversely
there's lots of things we can learn from
these other these other groups in the IT
world right so being developers we
always want to try the newest and
shiniest thing we're not always
necessarily that focused on reliability
and testing things like as much as we
should
so there's a whole there's groups of
people in our industry that have really
deep grained knowledge in those areas so
if we can kind of shift some of our
knowledge right shift some of their
knowledge left that helps with that
whole DevOps pipeline so that's the end
of this today now I will also point you
to you this is the website if you go to
WWE Adam
details on all the equipment I bought
here and how it all works
there is the Commodore 64 emulator you
can go crazy and write your own code and
do all kind of good stuff on there there
is also a the BBS terminal client you
can go and log on create an account join
in that world and enjoy I hope that was
useful I hope you can take away and be
either at least either a a better DevOps
citizen or at least have that mycrop
moment to share when you meet hands or
his brethren happy to take any questions
but other than that thank you very much
[Applause]